there is no mystery about what goes into
Jack Daniels whiskey the popular drink
has been around for 151 years and its
recipe is on the company's website but a
story about how Jack Daniel began his
distillery is only now gaining traction
Michelle Miller traveled to Tennessee to
learn how a man named nearest Greene
helped make the brand a household name
Michelle good morning good morning seem
to know a lot about whisky the first
clues about nearest Greene were in Jack
Daniels official biography published
back in 1967 Greene was mentioned in
this book about 50 times then his name
seemed to disappear until one woman
helped discover the truth at the heart
of how Jack Daniel came to make whiskey
it's important to set the record
straight because anyone who accomplished
something like nearest did should be
honored what nearest Greene a slave did
was teach Jack Daniel how to make
whiskey it was on the cover of The New
York Times international edition it was
possible that an african-american was
behind Jack Daniels and it's never been
spoken about until now for author Fon
Weaver finding the proof of Greene's
legacy has become a passion bordering on
obsession this is my research room over
the past year
Weaver's collected a library of
documents letters and pictures hoping to
parse the truth from folklore finally
one of the elders in the community and
she says well you know his name wasn't
really nearest well his name was Nathan
and he's from Maryland the oldest letter
here is from 1898 after digging for over
2,500 hours and speaking to more than a
hundred relatives it started to come
together like debbie staples a great
granddaughter of greens had heard the
tales of whiskey from her grandmother I
mean she had no reason to make up a
story like that in the late 1850s Jack
Daniel and orphan started working for a
wealthy landowner and whiskey distillery
and call this is where Jack Daniel grew
up okay call team Daniel with green one
of his slaves and his main whiskey man
and then after slavery he started his
own company and the person he went to
first was his mentor and he did not see
race as a barrier
she began pulling out all this research
Weaver
soon found evidence in black and white a
1972 article in the Tennessee historical
quarterly listed near a screen as Jack
Daniels first head distiller Marc
McCallum is the president of Jack
Daniels brands when we've known and
understood the weight of this story all
I can offer is anything we can do to
continue to honor the name of nearest we
will do the company first acknowledged
green is Jack Daniels mentor last year
there was an enormous amount of blowback
such as it ranged from some very
positive commentary on the story to some
very vitriolic it was a very tense time
in America as well and we then we were
into that month or two leading up to the
u.s. presidential election but I thought
the last thing that America needed at
that time was Jack Daniel to come out
again after all this commentary and
raise up this story again people had
been saying this for a very long time
but there was not one shred of proof and
so if you have a story that you know
will be controversial because most
people don't listen to the whole story
with who they're here immediately
Jack Daniel had slaves by all accounts
he did not it is believed that Daniel
opened his distillery in 1866 a year
after the 13th amendment abolished
slavery and working with Daniel helped
to make Greene and his children
wealthier than many of their white
neighbors master distillers
today Green is mentioned in tours of the
distillery that's Jack Daniel himself
and this is his crew
back in the early 1900s there's no known
photograph of nearest green but this is
his son George sitting right next to
Jack Daniel at a time when black
employees were often relegated to the
back three living Green descendants
still work at the distillery including
staples it means a lot to me to know
that now the world will know our country
is divided I know there's a lot of hate
going but you know to be in the south
and to have a relationship with someone
that's you would think that would never
happen despite the deep racial divides
of the American South in the 19th
century an improbable friendship brewed
one at the heart of a quintessentially
American brand for me this project ends
when I can go anywhere around the world
and say near screen and people know who
he is I have never lived in this type of
climate of race and when I look at this
story this is the one story that's
giving me hope through everything else
Weaver hopes to honor Greene's legacy by
building a Memorial Park we publishing
Jack Daniels biography and then creating
this new whiskey it's called uncle Maris
and the proceeds will go toward a
scholarship fund for the green for
greens living descendants and to support
the nearest green foundations various
efforts there is so much about that
relationship between these two men that
just astounded me and one of the things
that came out of this story was how Jack
Daniel treated his black and white
workers and he paid them essentially
according to fajn Weaver and according
to the distillery he paid them the same
wage for the same work yes back then
that and it was based on tenure Wow how
long you had been with the company I so
admired fawn Weaver I'm thinking what he
needed an investigation we need to call
her with the pretty I know it's all the
work that she's done that's an amazing
she's a passionate young
no wonder her dad was the author of love
child from Motown such an incredible an
incredible story and come by this is
this available yes it is it is available
so take us she's terrific what we
learned in history thank you great door
really really really beautifully done
thank you